[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to it's no
secret that the career of legendary
animator down Bluth has had some ups and
downs like anyone's like I see there's
been some hits and there's been some
misses but the hits seem to be when
Bluth had the most control over a
project and the missus seemed to be
whenever the studio he worked for took
the most control you can usually tell
the studio interference by how much the
film's imitated what was expected to be
popular at the time whether it be Disney
Star Wars or even other movies that
tried to rip off other genres or Disney
there was apparently a lot of mentally
Bluth was obviously known for its
beautiful style but was just as well
known for being wild aggressive and
imaginatively odd traditional fairy
tales or action films was not something
to expect out of such a uniquely strange
mind but the attempts were made and
often were not as successful as others
hoped but funny enough his weird style
shines in the last place you would
expect it a straight-to-video spin-off
of one of his Disney cinematic
knock-offs
it's the ouija 2 and Annabelle creation
of Don Bluth movies Bartok the
magnificent yes really
yes really
[Music]
directed by Don Bluth with Gary Goldman
and based on the comic relief from his
animated film Anastasia Bartok had the
animation budget of a straight-to-video
movie and honestly about as much
interest from the studio
they seemed understandably so more
interested in their cinematic release
than their smaller VHS tie-in but
because of this they interfered less
yeah we got a bizarre unique and
honestly kind of enjoyable little
special out of it it's not one of Blues
grand works or anything but it has more
of is traditionally odd signatures
resulting in a crazy but sir really
charming adventure and we're here to
look at this adorably insane film and
all its wonderfully head-scratching
glory so sit back and get ready to go
why as you show with any good Don Bluth
production this is Bartok the
magnificent the film opens with a song
about a witch named Baba Yaga which in
Russian translates to pointless but
funny throwaway joke an ant-man sequel
this immediately gives you a feel for
the film
this clearly little money thrown at this
there's not even that much animation to
start out but the stylized angles colors
and designs are already more unique than
what you usually see in the
direct-to-video product this looks like
Toys R Us if it went to hell no
disrespect don't miss it
we got pretty quickly to our main
character though a Russian bat named
Bartok played by Hank Azaria and before
you go insane he said he was open to a
real Russian bat voicing the part he
travels town to town telling fake tales
of his amazing heroics and even taking
out leftover animation cells from the
thief in the cobbler
damn those Russian bears always making
their way into the center of Moscow
Bartok seems to take out the bear though
without breaking a sweat
[Music]
yes I'm to the pile of other dead
carcasses my carriage is apparently
built for storing his antics caught the
attention of Prince Ivan
but his advisor Ludmila played by
Catherine O'Hara what's to stop him from
giving Bartok his royal ring or she'll
stab him with her chin well it's time
for a change he still leaves Bartok with
the ring though and us with the question
how much did Dimitri from the first film
get around cat go around giving royal
jewels to commoners well I wanted to
encourage him there are 15 people in
this house senior they all meet why
don't has to make trouble as you'd
imagine Bartok staged the bear attack
and the bear is actually his thespian
friend named Zozi played by Kelsey
Grammer well suffice it to say the
performance of my death today would have
shamed prometheus leaving us with the
question how much did Vladimir from the
first film get around I wish you could
hear yourself it's really quite
irritating critics I got the same
reaction from transformers four things
heat up though when the which turns the
palace into Sleeping Beauty backgrounds
and breaks into the princes room
[Music]
hey come on I put a lot into that
somebody notice
apparently the witch kid Nets the prints
leaving an iron tooth behind
Ludmila announces this to the residents
of moscow all 40 of them evil Baba Yaga
[Music]
yes the two children who clearly have an
understanding of strategic recovery
about to say okay the soldiers bring
Bartok to her and they request that he
saved the young prince from the iron
forest it would give me no greater
pleasure than to risk my life my
schedule is extremely tight mr. Bartok
oh boy here comes trouble
I like that Bartok essentially a cute
Don Bluth animation knows he's not gonna
be able to turn down a cute Don Bluth
animation oh god how is she doing that
the eyes are getting more and more done
blue fear okay okay just stop everything
going on in front of me so Bartok of
course agrees to save the prince and
Ozzy sings a song through tentacle
Candyland he's crying
[Music]
great can we get to the dark stuff whoa
this must be where they bury Muppets
so they come across a giant skull voiced
by Tim Curry who I swear with typecast
as giant CG green for a while do
you like it
riddles could you answer one do you have
Albert in a can you well you better let
the poor guy know the riddle is what key
opens a witch's door and the answer is a
skeleton key
but apparently Bartok is the only one
who can enter did you hear me say you
could go in unless you're worth the lies
far within the diamonds in the rough
which I seriously doubt your bear he
comes across the witches and a fully
rendered house and meets Baba Yaga okay
I know it's a short movie and you get a
squeeze in a lot of songs but do we have
to have one that has expecting her to
chase Dirk the daring with a rolling pin
into my hole she catches Bartok and says
he has to prove his worth and saving the
prince or die did south to the ice
quarry and bring pilaf - mewing pilaf
bring pilaf do you peel off it's either
a Russian fruit Russian viagra or a boat
so he journeys with Ozzy to find pilaf
who is a dog like caterpillar with such
an Cup hands played by jennifer Tilly
god I love a movie where I can say that
and it's not an exaggeration and when I
say stuck I mean playing the same bimbo
and everything even though I'm secretly
a freakin genius did you know I was
nominated for an Oscar no you didn't you
liar she even liked many of the
characters is adorably charming I love
to that Bartok actually knows how to do
a good karate chop it wasn't just a
throwaway line for the Anastasia trailer
okay it was by was put to good use here
but they have to answer another riddle
to enter the skull once more no matter
how hard you hit me no matter how much I
I'm always good for a laugh what am I
your role in Congo a funny bone same
thing
[Applause]
[Music]
so pilaf is returned to Baba Yaga and
she tells Bartok that he now has to get
the crown of obli these names sound like
onions Mario World characters in fact
the cast looks like them - you sure this
isn't Russian Mario maker
no he's actually a Space Age villain who
speaks fluent as median devil why do I
get the feeling this is one of those
delicious kids who eat in the Loompas a
nubile and libel and there's no such
place piss off bitch they get the crown
and take it back to the witch who says
the biggest challenge will be the
following day so Bartok takes a nap on
the floor and wakes up the next day
apparently the witch has no change of
clothes my god she must read the magic
from the sky she says she needs a magic
feather which Bartok also gets not sure
why he had to wait until morning to do
it but if I can follow a lead who looks
like the scientist from attack of the
killer tomatoes fuse begin the brain
together you should just accept the
weirdness I need something from you see
how he got the three objects he now
demands the prints but she says she
needs one last thing from him he gets so
fed up though that he yells at her and
makes her cry what are you doing Oh Baba
Yaga has feelings - suck on that Kurt
you ass I wish I could give you what you
need an emotional moment something
roland emmerich films never have she
puts the tear along with the other
ingredients he gathered and the house
shows him where the prince is at funny
enough it's back at the palace you never
took him did you I never said I did see
I'm not so bad I just like risking the
lives of others to do my dirty work but
the kids get a lesson kinda she gives
him a potion though that makes who we
truly is on the inside who he is on the
outside yeah I wouldn't do that Twitter
does something similar and it's not
pretty
Susie says he wants to help so he works
on a disguise so the villagers won't
recognize him what is this
Kevin you again any movie that has a
bear on a plate saying cabbage is really
doing something right anyways gotta be
fair those other character in suka
there are fun paedon for mum it's not so
much the costume is just imagining
kelsey grammer doing that voice that's
the sound like killer it's gonna make
before he cooks me
Bartek enters the palace and fights
Ludmila has appointed herself in charge
bartk says the princes in the tower but
hasn't put together yet there's
electrically only one character who
could possibly kidnapped him the girl in
the opening
nobody thank you without planning some
so it looks like she kidnapped that
Roman not do a caster so there's more
clever than it sounds and she drops the
prince the guard at bar talked down a
pit that I guess all towers have she
takes the potion herself and has I guess
no big shock a weird ass song number
it's the charming villain turns into
dragon number I'd be laughing more if I
wasn't certain that somebody somewhere
is getting turned on by this you know
you're out there you're weird so Z helps
rescue Bartok and the prince while
liudmila attacks the thousands are
dozens of villagers throughout Moscow
we don't like zack snyder's reboot of
Figment Bartok tries to stop the dragon
and leads her back to the palace
[Music]
you know the thought occurs to me
there's a lot of female animated dragons
aren't there even though I never knew or
cared about this before my gender feels
demeaned bartk tricks the dragon into
falling over ending her short fiery
reign baba yaga trots by as well as
Bartok says she owes him a hug how
strangely hideous and cute you might be
wondering where my girlfriend was from
the end of the last movie well maybe
it's a prequel which means I'm gonna
suddenly turn evil in the next one I
guess kind of confusing you know what
there was no meg Ryan in this so count
your blessings Bartok the magnificent is
a very cute fun imaginative little film
that for what it is I think holds of
better than the film that's bonded
Anastasia was trying to mix weird with
conventional coming off as kind of
unbalanced this one just embraces the
weird and tells a smaller story on a
smaller budget meaning they have to rely
a lot more on charm and uniqueness and
even though it's for a younger audience
I really feel it works I love watching
these characters interact a lot
Adventures misunderstand things befall
themselves it's odd but it's kind of
irresistible so much so that apparently
the studio wanted to run this on the big
screen but both bluefin Goldman said
none of the dimensions or resolution
were correct for cinema so even though
it's direct-to-video he's don't see this
as a Don Bluth film and a really
enjoyable one it's no classic like
secret of NIMH or Land Before Time but
it's a lot of innocent and weird fun if
you got kids or heck even one check it
out for yourself there's surprisingly a
lot more magic to this than you would
expect
I thought Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
you
cabbage
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
prevent child abuse America this
organization was founded in 1972 as the
first organization in the United States
whose sole purpose is to prevent the
abuse and neglect of our nation's
children it undertakes its mission by
effecting change at the governmental and
community level on the systems that
support the full range of services
needed to promote the child development
process and provide parents with better
conditions to be the kind of parents
they want to be based in Chicago they
have state chapters in 47 states and
over 400 healthy families America sites
together approximately 500 staff in the
national office and chapters manages
over three hundred and fifty three
different locally based strategies to
meet the mission of the organization if
you look at their site in their YouTube
channel you can see all the live
varieties of ways they help both
children and adults earning them an A+
rating on charity watch click on the
link and help create so many happy
children parents and Families
you